how did you become South savitur is a
version of Barry from the future he
remembers it everything that Barry does
when a fairy can't remember what we're
doing now when you created flashpoint
you want wittingly provided me with the
means for my return you gave me idea to
turn Wally into Kid Flash to make him
fast enough to replace me is your prison
he's used ego were my allies so taken
with his name and speed she never saw he
was running right into my place how do I
get him out while he's gone how do I get
him off suffering in an endless void for
all eternity
another victim Barry Allen failed to say
hey everybody is Charlie so everyone's
got so many questions about sabotage so
I'll try to explain everything there's a
new round of the flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so which version of Barry is this and
how is the flash our flash going to
defeat him if he already knows every
single thing he's going to do because he
already lived it that's the real
challenge this season season 2 was all
about zoom using other people and
someone inside the team like his time
remnant pretending to be Jay Garrick
savage heart doesn't need to do that but
a lot of defeating him depends on what
his origin story is that's also why I
included those clips at the beginning of
this sabotage says and does not say a
couple really important things implying
where he came from in what the key to
defeating him is going to be so the most
important thing that I think a lot of
people are forgetting is this avatar
predates flashpoint when he was trying
to pull Wally into the Speed Force to
replace him so that he could get out he
said he saw what Barry did when he went
back in time to save his mother and
thought of an opportunity because the
thing that we don't really know about
the Speed Force prisons that's another
big question so just open up a tab and
leave it in chrome because they say that
one person always has to be inside the
Speed Force prison so Jay Garrick can be
in there it can be Barry it can be evil
Barry it can be Wally it doesn't matter
what your genetics are it's not like you
have to be another version of Barry from
somewhere else in the multiverse or
somewhere else in his timeline it's one
of the biggest logic problems for this
show that they haven't figured out yet
but it's avatar predates flashpoint that
means he's a future version of Barry
from a timeline that predates flashpoint
meaning he's either from the original
timelines that we never saw the timeline
from before season 1 season 1 was the
beginning of the new timeline because it
was the first time that the
reverse-flash made the decision to come
back and kill his mother then we have
season 1 Barry tries to go back and save
his mother but hesitates you have season
2 he finally can't stop himself after
the death of his father goes back
creates flashpoint then walks that back
with the help of the reverse-flash and
now technically we're in the fourth
timeline so you have the original
timeline which we never saw the second
time line which was season 1 most of
season 2 and then a brief flashpoint
timeline before he went
back and changed it and created the
fourth timeline which we're living in
right now I really do like the idea that
Savitt R is the original future berry
regardless of which timeline he's from
the reason why he was able to survive
flashpoint is because the Speed Force is
this extra dimensional energy field that
exists beyond time and space like when
Eddie killed himself this version of the
reverse-flash vaporized but the previous
version from earlier in his timeline was
safe because he was traveling through
the Speed Force looking for Barry Allen
so the Speed Force was protecting him
but he became a time remnant and I know
everybody's wondering how come the black
flash doesn't come first avatar if he's
changing time I think part of that is
because the black flash serves the will
of the Speed Force in the Speed Force
itself is allowing this to play out so
that Barry can learn this important
lesson he spent all of episode 16
talking to those Speed Force wormhole
aliens learning about the consequences
of his actions that a price has to be
paid very slowly learning that he's
going to have to pay that price
eventually but defeating savitur is so
hard because of all the twists with the
philosopher's stone
normally Savitt are whichever timeline
he came from now that he's part of this
timeline would still be subject to
things that Barry chained so if Barry
chopped his hand off it doesn't matter
where Savitt Ark came from if he's
future Barry his hands going to
disappear too so one of the big reasons
why saboteur is trying to kill iris is
one he probably grew up in a time line
where he wasn't with iris maybe he
didn't even know her so he doesn't care
about her so are Barry who is in love
with her might see her die experiences
crazy tragedy and become Savitt are on
the road to trying to stop him if he's a
self-fulfilling prophecy in savat our
would prevent Barry from erasing his
future I'm going to be back and forth on
the iris thing because it just sounds
like it's a future version of our Barry
but he spits in his face in that clip
that I included when he says one more
person that Barry Allen failed to save
so it just sounds like saboteur failed
to save someone or a bunch of people and
that's what put him on the path to
becoming Savitt are going super evil
I'll get rid of my pain by becoming a
Speed God and now he's been Darth Vader
for so long he's completely forgot what
it's like to be our version of
area on who was in love with Iris so
just remember during different time
lives Barry got his powers at different
points in the timeline then he could
have gotten his powers through the
philosopher's stone some completely
different way than our version of Barry
did but hopefully that explains why
saboteur would kill iris just because
he's trying to get Barry to become
Savitt are otherwise his future is going
to be rewritten and he'll just vaporize
into nothing that's the same way the
reverse-flash did but what that means is
that in order to defeats avatar Barry is
going to have to change something
fundamental about himself and he'll just
wink out of existence but I think the
idea is is that when they fight and they
will definitely continue to fight the
next couple of episodes Barry will just
get his ass handed to him because not
only is avatar much faster that's why
his lightening is white because he has a
much stronger connection to the Speed
Force like you've noticed the Barry gets
faster and faster each season Savatage
had that many more years to learn that
many new tricks but do not forget about
Jessie quicks avatar said he had special
plans for her and I think it mostly has
to do with her intellect in trying to
twist Wally West because she's a good
speedster on her own but she's
incredibly smart she's a genius in what
are a couple different ways to
neutralize Wally West he's in love with
Jessie quick just think of what he would
do to try and save her so it's really
just avatar messing with all of team
flash just trying to push Barry over the
edge so that he'll go crazy in sabot r
will continue to exist in some form in
the future what I really want to see
though is how he got that scar in his
face I'm not expecting to see too many
savitur flashbacks with the exception of
him explaining who he is in which
timeline he came from I can imagine it
now I'm the original version of you
you made all these changes you erase me
don't I have the right to exist like
that's the typical villain thing so
they've been a lot of comic-book changes
when they finally reveal what the actual
twist is like depending on which
direction the riders go I'll explain how
it's different from the comics we've
already changed a whole bunch of Mark
Waid stuff as well as the blue flash
from the future blue flash has more
moral ground to stand on when it comes
to defeating Barry Allen buts avatar
doesn't want to kill Barry he wants to
get Barry to become himself blue flash
Barry was just legit trying to kill
himself so that he would be erased from
time line all together but let me know
where do you think thats avatar came
from did he come from a different time
line it has to be from before flashpoint
so which version of berry do you think
he is do you think he's the future of
original berry or do you think he's some
other version but what's going to happen
next is I have some new Rick and Morty
if I get it done in time I'll post it
but there's a whole bunch of stuff
happening tomorrow there's new
spider-man homecoming trailer there's a
new Wonder Woman trailer so I'll do
videos for those whenever they drop
it'll be sometimes Sunday night
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner RTT gamer please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details while you
wait for everything click here for my
guardians of the galaxy post credits
video and you can click here to learn
about all the big comic book changes
they made thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight